Jenny is with us in Kansas City hi Jenny
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi Dave
thanks for talking to me today sure
what's up
well my husband was killed in an
accident on his way to work last fall
and we are receiving some benefits and
now I'm trying to figure out what to do
with the money yeah and they're all like
life insurance policy type benefits sure
how old was he
42 oh my goodness I'm sorry yes don't
worry y'all married 20 years young
children do exist even seventeen fifteen
and seventeen
and how much life insurance did you
receive well so far about 350,000
there's still an insurance policy
because it was an accident the driver
was driving the wrong way highway and so
that has not paid out yet so that'll be
probably another 125 okay which probably
the max of their policy theirs was
$25,000 for access where would the other
hundred come from from the vehicle he
was driving all these drivers gonna come
if somebody was in the company vehicle
yeah
and that had a max on it too then all
right yes yes oh my goodness okay um
okay and what did your husband that used
to make what was in turn fifty to sixty
thousand what were you working at that
time yes what do you make now 15 to 20
and are you still doing that yes okay I
have I have my own son okay still I
receive workman's comp check now from
from that from his company yes why he
was in a vehicle to come any vehicle -
yes okay Wow he was
yeah and how much is the workman's comp
check it's twenty seven hundred dollars
a month how long will that go on the
rest of my life okay all right and the
kids will get social security until
they're 18 right well so so he was
bringing in take-home pay about $4,000 a
month
2,700 of that has been replaced all
right okay and so we need the rest of
this money to create another two to
three thousand dollars income right
I have only debt I have is the house
good and how much do you owe on your
home 98 thousand okay all right so
there's two ways you can go your house
payment is how much 888-844-3362 money
well in the middle of your grief which
it would be understandable if you didn't
a lot of times you know but what we
don't want to do is it is to go along
and not have a plan because you you know
you're married 20 years you've got
teenagers this is the this hurts and
when you're hurting you can spin through
money like water you know I'm saying
yeah it's real easy to do and you want
to want to put a thing you want to put a
little system in place to protect you
from yourself kind of thing and say you
know what I would do is
let's pay are you gonna stay in the home
yeah let's pay off the house and let's
invest everything else and use only the
income off of it and pledge to never
touch the principal okay if you pull if
you invest four hundred thousand dollars
and you in and let's just use round
numbers again let's say it made ten
percent
that'd be forty thousand dollars a year
but you only need two thousand dollars a
month that be twenty four thousand a
year so if you invested four hundred
thousand and it made ten percent and you
only took twenty four thousand off a
year you would have been you be living
better income then you had slightly
better income than you had
mathematically when he was here income
home Lee's all I'm talking about I'm not
saying it's better it's not better
income the math is better and it'd be
slightly better and it would still be
growing you not only would not be
depleting it you would let be letting it
grow slightly which is an ideal
situation okay so what I would tell you
to do is pay off your house and let's
set aside an emergency fund of three to
six months of expenses and I'm going to
invest the rest of it and carefully
selected mutual funds with a smart
investor pro who will help you and you
sit down with them with the heart of a
teacher you learn about this stuff you
don't trust me
you don't trust someone else it's not
that they will steal from you but you
need to understand what you're doing and
that way you have peace about it
okay when you get anxiety around
investments is because you didn't know
what you were doing great there's also a
401 K of about twenty five thousand
dollars oh yeah we'll just roll that to
an IRA so we don't need to touch it
either it'll just grow we'll just let it
sit intact and the tax free rollover
direct rollover so click on Dave Ramsey
calm click on smart Wester it'll drop
down a list of the smart investor pros
in your area select which one you'd like
to talk to sit down they'll have the
heart of a teacher you
take your time you can let the money sit
in a simple CD if you want for a little
while until you feel good about this but
I'm saying if you were to invest this
money in good mutual funds and it made
10 to 12 percent and you pulled off less
than that that is ideal okay so his
workers comp and a mutual fund throwing
you $2,000 a month puts you at 4700 with
no house payment right and you're gonna
have about 400 K total after paying off
the house if you get the other 125 right
right exactly so that's the numbers I
got so you know you should be making 40
and burning 24 that's that's what I'm
thinking or better it might turn out
better than that but something like that
and that'll the good news about that is
the goose will couldn't perpetually lay
these golden eggs perpetually this can
go on as you said like the workers comp
for the rest of your life so I'm so
sorry honey I'm so sorry you guys are
facing this you call me anytime I can
help if you get confused about something
or scared you call me I'll walk with you
through this you can do this and click
on smart investor and get somebody to
help you in your corner with the
investing and set up a system that
protects you from you